s'il ya deux ans les gm et les jeux
seront à moliets les géo les gentils
organisateurs gm les gentils membres du
club med
le conseil général des landes a en effet
donné à l'unanimité son feu vert pour
l'implantation d'un club méditerranée à
moliets informations dont touristique de
première importance
mais surtout ce club méditerranée 2000
il y créera 250 emplois directs le
conseil général des landes offre le
terrain coût de ce club 250 millions de
francs
le reportage un tout petit peu moins
cher dany d'éléments évoluant au conseil
général des landes qui siége est
aujourd'hui en séance extraordinaire
un invité inhabituelle aux côtés du
président emmanuelli
le directeur général du club
méditerranée car il s'agissait de savoir
si le club s'implante à moliets réponse
oui moliets aujourd'hui deux parcours de
golf 18 et 9 trous signée trent jones un
cloud 11 courts de tennis un parcours de
tir à l'arc des pistes cyclables
moliets demain un village club 2010
autour du golf un centre d'initiation
langues
un centre de séminaires un centre de
thalassothérapie les landes offre le
terrain 16 millions monsieur trigano
investi 250 millions potentiel de
clients à venir
25000 les retombées économiques
importantes
il ya d'abord des retombées en termes
d'emplois directs et indirects je dirais
que 280 une direct 500-600 ne sait pas
bien surtout je crois phénomène est fait
de l'image de marque à la fois pour les
lan mais je pense pour l'aquitaine pour
la côte atlantique aquitaine c'est la
première fois que le club méditerranée
s'installe sur l'atlantique et je pense
que nous allons tous ont bénéficié
est-ce que les départements prend un
risque sur le plan financier on le
département va apporter le terrain c'est
à dire ça correspond à peu près une
subvention de 6,4 pour cent sur le prix
du village il va participer à la
thalassothérapie mais là disons qui va
le financer avec la taxe professionnelle
qui reçoit ce mendiant on investit pour
recevoir mais je crois que c'est la
règle moderne on peut pas faire
autrement
l'implantation du club méditerranée un
site d'ores et déjà des investisseurs à
s'intéresser à moliets investisseurs
français et espagnols notamment la côte
landaise joue là une grosse carte son
avenir touristique a été examinée avec
attention d'autant que de récentes
affaires d'investissement affaire aura
notamment restent encore dans les
mémoires
le produit club a paru très sérieux aux
conseillers généraux
ouverture prévue dans deux ans